et on en vient maintenant à la crise
sanitaire et la levée des restrictions
qui se poursuit tant l'italie où le port
du masque en extérieur n'est plus
obligatoire décision annoncée vendredi
dernier par le ministre de la santé
roberto spéranza et cela fait suite aux
bons résultats obtenus avec la campagne
de vaccination le couvre feu il a pris
fin également dans la vallée d'aoste
dernières régions soumises à cette
mesure à la semaine passée on a noté une
chute de 36% à des contaminations en
italie on en parle tout de suite avec
camilla genovese un médecin un bilan
bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors d'abord
quelle est la situation actuelle au
niveau épidémique en italie les les
indicateurs sont plutôt encourageants
c'est ça bonjour on arrive à avoir une
amende de 1000 cas par jour
celle qui est un très bon résultat en
comptant le fait qu'on a plus ou moins
200 mille tests qui s'effectue par jour
donc c'est un très bon résultat
c'est vrai que voilà faut toujours être
alerte alors la prévalence du variant
delta était de 16 8% le 21 juin contre
4,2 en mai c'est ce qu'ont annoncé
d'ailleurs les autorités sanitaires
vendredi comment vous appréhendez
justement l'évolution du variant c'est
ça c'était effectivement une réalité à
laquelle il fallait s'attendre le
parlant d'état circulent il circule de
plus en plus et voilà les les conseils
voilà ce restent toujours les mêmes il
faut toujours faire attention même si
des restrictions sont en train de
diminuer
c'est vrai qu'il est un peu à nous en
tant que si tu as lien citoyen à faire
attention à continuer avec les maintenir
la licence tant qu'on peut selon vous la
décision de renoncer justement au port
du masque en extérieur dès ce matin est
ce qu'elle est trop hâtive cette
décision alors c'est vrai que il faut
être à jour avec ce qui se passe en
europe je sais qu'en france le masque
était enlevé il ya quelques semaines
à l'extérieur si la distance peut être
maintenue et on fait attention je ne
vois pas pourquoi on devrait
voilà contient le garder c'est vrai que
voilà la liste ans doit toujours
maintenu entre nous c'est l'intention la
situation actuelle dans les hôpitaux
italiens que ce qu'on pouvait nous dire
là-dessus alors la pression sur les
hôpitaux en train de diminuer c'est vrai
que les faits puis légère avec moins
d'hospitalisations dans les services de
médecine et dans les réanimations que ce
soit pour le vaccin ou pour la période
d'été ça et on va voir dans les
prochains mois qu'est ce qui va se
passer
alors il ya évidemment une polémique en
italie autour de la vaccination des
soignants les sanctions donc contrôler
le personnel de santé qui refusent la
vaccination c'est effectif depuis mardi
cela concerne la suspension des salaires
changement de fonction ou mise en congé
forcé votre avis là-dessus tout d'abord
voilà en tant que médecins et
scientifiques
c'est vrai que et j'espère ne pas
pouvoir parler aussi pour les infirmiers
et les opérateurs sanitaires
il est un peu à nous de donner le bon
exemple et de connaître
qu'est ce qui se passe avec les vaccins
donc très content d'être les premiers à
être vaccinés pour entendre pour
protéger nos patients et toutes les
personnes qui nous entourent mais
comment vous visez cette décision des
autorités ce qui a quand même cette
obligation
alors c'est vrai que beaucoup de banques
semblent être obligatoire qui à notre
jour et c'est vrai que voilà je pense
vraiment a tant que médecin qu'il est il
est fondamental pour nous de nous
vacciner est de protéger nos citoyens
voilà donc
j'espère que mes collègues
bon ça vacciner aussi pour pour eux
mêmes et pour tous ceux qui les
entourent
on va le voir dans le courant de cette
édition que la situation allait plutôt
inquiétante dans certains pays en russie
en australie au bangladesh notamment on
voit que bon en europe 1
on allège les restrictions ça va
beaucoup mieux mais comment est ce que
vous vous voyez les mois à venir en
termes d'évolution de l'épidémie 1 alors
mais j'espère de poux faut rester
optimiste
je suis toujours optimiste c'est vrai
que voilà je compte aussi beaucoup sur
mes concitoyens et j'espère que l'on va
tous nous appliquer pour que le virus ne
se propage pas et c'est vrai qu'avec la
nommant son déployante d'abord qu'est ce
qui se passe dans le futur mais c'est
vrai que à ce jour on ne peut pas
vraiment prédire qu'est ce qu'il se
passera dans quelques mois on verra
et donc la vaccination là les campagnes
de vaccination qui avance bien en europe
ça peut être un moyen efficace justement
pour contrer une nouvelle vague
à la rentrée c'est ça voilà l'important
c'est de continuer à se vacciner et de
vacciner le plus de personnes possible
on me verra si voilà les vaccins 100 m
efficace contre les variants mais
l'important c'est de vacciner le plus de
personnes possible afin de limiter la
propagation de ces virus
merci beaucoup avoue camille genovese
médecin d'avoir répondu à nos questions
en direct sur arte france